what's going on everybody welcome back
to another coding tech original
i am your host michael j griffin jr and
now you can see my face
so today we are going to discuss css and
i have
six cool css tricks to show you alright
so three of them will be for page layout
and three will be for content inside of
the page all right
so without further ado let's get started
all right you see i've got my terminal
window
open here uh bumped it up the screen
size so that you can see
uh and then i'm gonna you know start
just using some commands here all right
so
if you're ready with me i'm already in
my uh desktop all right so i'm going to
uh create a directory here call it css
tricks all right i'm going to see the
into that directory
and then i'm going to create my outline
file all right
so what i'll do here is i'll open vs
code
so that we can begin doing this inside
of vs code all right
so the outline file now if you you were
part of the last video you kind of got a
preview of what i'm going to be doing
with the outline file i'm just going to
bring it in here
all right let's bring it it's a markdown
file
all right so this is going to keep me on
track
so that i know you know where i'm going
and then we'll also put this
in the um in the repository and you can
actually see how i think about things
and
you know maybe take some tips and tricks
and if you have some uh tips for me
by all means send them in all right so
in the comments below okay
so let me preview this i'm gonna command
uh
kv okay so that's one of the things that
you know
i forgot to mention in the last video
what i'm gonna do here
in this video is just make sure i send a
plug out uh for the plugin
uh send a plug out for the plugin that
i'm using to view this markdown all
right
so it's called markdown preview enhanced
and you can go here and just search for
it in marketplace
and i already have it installed but the
idea is you can
view your markdown and i use this as my
you know outline just kind of go through
things
all right so uh install that if you want
to do the same thing that i'm doing here
okay
so you see we've got our outline over
here you're just gonna walk through
we're going to walk through everything
you see i even remind myself right make
sure that the webcam is lower right
corner and turn on do not disturb okay
so our basic outline basic setup sidebar
layout
pancake layout pancake with sidebars
layout
one line center evenly spaced cards and
c-span grid so these three
will be page layout and these three will
be about
will be the internal contents layout all
right so
let's get right to it so we've already
got our directory everything else is set
up i'm going to open up the terminal
in visual studio code and we'll get
started all right
so i'm going to get rid of normal keep
that there all right so let's get
right to it okay so we're going to do
we're going to use this file
i'm going to use this command uh right
here in the terminal oh you got to
remember to bump this up some yeah
i want to make sure i bump that up so
everybody can see all right so we're
going to touch a main.css
uh yeah so that's going to be the file
that we're using there actually what i
want to do
is i want to be over here and then when
i create that perfect all right
main.css and you'll be able to i'm
scrolling back down it's one of the
things about the plugin is that it
always
goes back to the bottom all right but
i'm not complaining because it's do
you know it it's pretty awesome all
right so
uh i'm gonna add this right so for every
one of our files
uh we're gonna import the main.jss that
just basically gives us some
uh basic body styling and removes all
the padding and
margins from uh from the document to
start off with all right so without
let's get to the first one
sidebar layout all right we're gonna
touch sidebar layout.html
create that file we're gonna touch
sidebar layout
and again if you wanted to create these
files over here by just clicking you
know new file you could do that too all
right
i'm just i like to use the command line
because it it keeps me honest so we
already did that
all right so let me copy and paste this
one sorry
uh let me copy and paste this all right
boom okay it just created a pdf for me i
don't know why
all right here we go let's do that there
we go all right so here we go let me
get rid of that so we have more space
all right so i'm going to open up
sidebar layout all right
sidebar layout.html i'm going to create
uh with emmit
uh which comes pre-installed right from
the last video
uh yeah it's been so long it's been so
long since i had done this emmit we had
to installed it when i installed visual
studio code
first but now it comes pre-packaged
which is great all right
so sidebar layout it's basically html
colon five it gives us an html5 skeleton
all right so we're going to add these
files or these
links to these files inside of the head
okay and i have
a prettier installed right you can see
down here prettier is installed and it's
doing the formatting on
autosave all right so let's add the
following code to our sidebar layout
all right uh here we go so we got a
container
we got a sidebar uh and we've got some
content
all right so let me reload this because
i see that um
that there we go all right live server
was not up so i'm going to click go live
so that we can see this
all right now to bring this over here
all right so you can see
that this is nothing now right it's
nothing okay
well it's something but it's not what we
want all right so
uh but it has the you know the body the
main styling is there right it's removed
all the
the padding and all that other stuff all
right so let's get back
to what we were doing oh outline's gone
all right let me bring it back up
okay here we go we're still on our basic
setup all right
so where are we okay here we go all
right so let's add the following code
and then i'll explain it what i'll
explain what it's doing i'm gonna go to
sidebar layout i'm gonna paste this in
okay and what we'll do is we'll go back
and look
oh wait okay so we've got some problems
up you know why
because i forgot a dot
all right the dot the dot is the cs is
the is the dot
the semicolon of css right
okay so this is what we've got all right
so we got our sidebar a little coffee
sidebar okay so we got our sidebar here
and let me explain to you
what's happening here okay so this is
how we created our sidebar we started
off
with display grid all right display grid
uh you know starts by uh turning the
page or whatever container
uh that you're using a parent into uh
a grid all right and then we tell it
what we want our grid to look like
all right we use that by um setting the
grid template columns
and we we're using in this instance
we're using the min max function to say
the minimum
amount of width that the side the first
column can take
is 150 pixels and then this uh and the
maximum that it can take is 25
of the entire window all right and then
the other one just takes up
whatever's left right that's one
fractional unit just whatever's left
of the page you get to take it up right
so we start with display grid and then
we set the grid template columns
and voila right we have got
a fully functioning sidebar and then
again we can start to
add other stuff inside of the sidebar
but for all intents and purposes our
sidebar is there
and it was just you know one line of
code that did this for us all right
so that's number one number two okay the
pancake
layout all right so let's get straight
to it we're gonna do
pretty much the same thing we're going
to touch pancake layout all right we're
going to touch
pancake.css and touch is just the mac uh
command that says hey if this file
doesn't exist create it
otherwise if it does exist update the
modified date okay
so that's all that's doing all right so
we're going to open up
pancakelayout.html we're going to create
uh our emmet document all right
and we will add to our newly formed
document then it's an html document
created with within it all right
uh so oh that's in the wrong spot
all right so we're adding this to the
header head of our document again the
main css and then pancakelayout.css
all right so now we need to add some
content so
let's do that we got our container we've
got a header
we've got main we've got footer all
right
so you'll probably notice this when you
see it all right but let's let's take a
look at it
we'll close this kill it uh and add live
server back
all right so this is what's happening
now we just got three
like stacked up right there like what is
this this is this is nothing right we
need to do something with this let's
make it look good
all right so to do that we need to add
some stuff to
the container i'm sorry the css file so
we're going to copy that code and then
again i'll explain it as we're walking
through all right and i don't think i
explained the container but basically
the container
is it's gonna display grid i did explain
the last one all right display grid
let's go back over to that and we'll see
what we created right
so this is our header and this is our
footer and
right they're taking up right so the
header and the footer
are and we'll explain it let me explain
it but you can see what's happening
right this is great basically creating a
full page layout
with the header and the footer um you
know demarcations
of that and then the middle was just
taking up whatever's left okay
so let's discuss what this is doing all
right so
we've got display grid we tell it take
up 100 uh
of the view height all right 100 units
of the view height that means all of it
100
basically all right and then we say for
our pancake layout we're going to say
what our grid template rows are remember
we talked about
grid template columns that's was across
now we're going up and down
and we and basically what we're saying
is we want three of them right so auto
one fr and auto so auto says take up
whatever space that i have
whatever whatever content whatever space
my content takes up
that's how much space i take up right
and then one fractional unit is
whatever's left of the screen
the main the middle one is going to take
up and then auto this is the footer
it's going to do the same thing that the
head is doing is taking up all of the
space that it can't
its content takes up and i'll show you
uh what i mean by that right
so the header this is basic stuff right
the padding is 1.5 room unit
uh color white background navy is just
basically giving it some styling to
um you know figure out which ones what
like change the color all right
but let me show you what i mean by it
taking up the amount of
space that the content takes up so if i
were to add uh to the footer let's just
add let's just say i use lorem
laura mipsum right um yeah so lorem
ipsum will do lorem
1000 how what what why not right
lorem 1000. i go back and look at what
the footer is doing the footer is like
okay you told me i could have whatever i
want whatever i feel like it's like
chrome with memory
okay like if you tell it it can have
whatever it's gonna take it
okay and that's basically what auto's
doing right whatever whatever you give
me i'm gonna take
okay so we pull it back down and now it
just says lower one
1000 which is weird you don't want it to
say lower one thousand let's go back now
you've got something that looks actually
looks decent right so that's a pancake
layout all right so let's get to
pancake with sidebar so we got we're
gonna you can figure out it's gonna look
like the pancake but it's gonna have
sidebars
uh for the you know in the main content
all right so let's get
right to it okay so here we go we're
gonna do the same thing i'll close that
out
uh pancake layout and pancake.css
all right then we'll open up the pancake
sides page
and there it is pancake sides we'll
create that within
it all right and then we'll open up
oh we got to add these right we got to
add these css
see it's very consistent right it's very
consistent it's not like this is not
rocket science all right
so and you can see how i think like i
just have to like step by step by step
by step by step
okay so and uh the following code we got
to add this to our pancake
layout.html right so we're going to have
it's very similar right container
header but this is where the magic
happens right oh you got a left sidebar
a right side right in the right sidebar
and your main and then the footer all
right
so how we do that using css grid and
you'll see a lot of this is going to be
css grid and flexbox and we'll put some
links in the description
description below so that you can see uh
you can kind of get your feet wet
if you if this is your first time with
uh the grid and flexbox okay
so let's add this code to the
pancakelayout.css all right
and again i will explain it as after i
uh add it all right so and i'll do this
i'll close this
out oh sorry i didn't mean to reload it
but you know what sometimes things
happen
all right so let me open
let me open the outline and do
yup sorry let's do that okay v
all right there you go all right so
where were we where where are we
all right here we go okay so we've added
we're adding the css code
all right that's where we were all right
see sometimes i remember things
all right so we're gonna add the css
code and we're going to go
live not reload okay so well boy
oh that's nothing that's a big block oh
that's because i did it on the
uh all right let me dispose that and now
let's start it because it's like
i don't know what to do with css all
right so we've got our header
we got our footer we got our main and we
got our two side bars all right
so let me change the uh the color of
these sidebars
because they don't uh let's do
uh wheat there you go wheat
and for the right sidebar we'll do uh
oh chart reuse why not all right that'll
make it really stand out
yes it does all right so our header up
here probably should make uh that header
yeah let's just make the color of that
head or whatever's in the color
there we go all right white there you go
okay perfect now we can see it
all right so now we got our left side
bar and our right side bar so let's
explain
what's going on here okay so pancake
sides
let's show you what we got okay
so pancake size here we go all right
that's the pancake layout sorry no
no it's pancake size all right i just
didn't put this that's a mistake right
there
okay so again display grid 100 uh view
width so that's the full the full right
the full thing so our basic three column
layout though
all right so these are our rows
and these are our columns okay so this
is shorthand
all right for our rows auto take up auto
it's basically the same thing as the
pancake layout
auto one fractional unit auto that's the
same thing right
but for the columns we're doing the same
thing auto one fractional unit
auto right so for the columns it's gonna
be three right we got three rows
three columns that's how you can look at
this okay and it was just telling it
what we wanted to do
all right so then that means we have to
change some things about how we do our
header right because
initially if we were to just take this
let me let me show you why
right what would happen if we didn't do
anything we just said hey header be a
header
right well it's like well i'm just going
to take up this one column by default
that's what i'm going to do all right so
we need to tell it
how far we want it to span across all
right so
let's say hey you start at line
one i'll start that yeah start at line
one right here
all right and then i want you to end at
line four right so there's one
if like let's just let's say one this
would be two this would be three
and this would be four right so that
that's why it's going all the way across
so it's not
stop and take up three columns it's
actually
the line start at line one and end at
line four
because if you have three columns set in
your grid uh
your grid column template columns you
have four lines
right so that's how you can think about
that so i want you to i want you to go
start at row one or start at column one
or line one
and end at line four so whenever you
want to take up a full amount you could
basically just say okay i'm gonna
subtract
and that's how many columns it's going
to take up four minus one is going to
take up three columns okay
all right so padding one rim oh yeah
right so left sidebar this is this is
where we actually do a little bit more
work because the footer is the same same
as the other
all right so the left side bar we're
basically saying
look i'm gonna i'm gonna pull this over
here so that i can explain it while i'm
doing that all right
so the left side bar i want you to start
at line one and end
start at line one end at line two okay
and then for the main i want you to
start at line two and end at line three
you can basically see like two minus one
is just one column three minus two one
column right
four minus one i mean four minus three
one right so start that one
number three and at number four okay so
that's how you can get uh
a you know pretty cool sidebar thing
going on right i mean it's
yeah it's pretty simple right you can do
what you need to do in inside of the
content here
but you've got your header your you know
sidebars your main
and your footer okay so that's the third
of our page layouts now
let's move some to some of the uh
content inside of the page and how we
can
use flexbox and grid on some of these
modern css techniques
in order to uh achieve some of the
common things that we see
all right uh there's common things that
we want to do with css okay
so let's open up sidebar layout all
right sidebar
layout all right and we're gonna add
something to the content all right so
let's just change this content
uh to actually have something in it okay
so let's go back and look at this
all right and i probably should have
just you know what man let's go live
again we'll do it
all right all right so we got the
pancake size and pancake all right so
now we have we have all three of them
open
all right but look at our coffee cup man
we don't want that thing
like it's just hanging out over there we
want to center it right we want to want
it to be in the center so how do we do
that all right
so let's go to our css and we'll change
the content
so we'll do display grid and look at
this look at this
place items in the center simple as that
one line and our little coffee cup is
hanging out in the center
by himself okay so all right that's
that's pretty cool right if you've had
to center things in the past
uh centering them in with one line
should be
pretty exciting all right and i'm gonna
uh create something a little bit
yeah i'll i need to create something in
main css give this little guy because
he's just sitting out there doing
nothing
all right here we go yeah make him yeah
there you go he's a little bit bigger
all right okay cool okay so
we've got that one that's that was our
number one for the uh content based
css trick number two the second um
content-based css trick is evenly spaced
cards
all right so let's go let's open up uh
pancake layouts
and we're gonna change our main to look
like this all right so i'm gonna bring
the main
and it will explain kind of what's going
on so main is not gonna just be main
anymore okay let's go over here and look
and see what
happened let's refresh okay cool
that's weird looking right okay so we
got coding tech
lessons uh you know put a little avatar
in there but
we want to make some cards right so
let's do that let's go here
and these card classes that we created
we need to give them some styling
all right so let's go into main.css
because we'll probably use these cards
again we want our cards to be
yeah interesting all right so now so now
they look more like cards all right
so how can we though uh make these
things
look like actual cards that are you know
taking up a third of the space of the
container that
that we want them in so let's go back to
uh sidebar now this is where i'm going
to explain like pancake sides
all right yeah that's what we're doing
right pancake size yes all right so i'm
going to go here
and i'm going to take this and now
cool right all right so let me explain
what i just did though
all right so we've got we've got the
real deal happening over here okay let
me move that
all right so let's and they're actually
stacking too
all right so let's see what we what we
did so we've got our
uh evenly spaced card all right so the
idea is
that everything inside of this card will
be evenly spaced so that if i were to
get rid of this lorem text
the card sizes would stay the same right
they're actually not going to shrink and
grow
based on uh the amount of content inside
unless it goes greater
then yeah you can right they'll also
they'll expand with each other
but they won't shrink to the point where
you can't
uh you can't visually tell like these
are supposed to be even or not no
all right and let me show you what the
trick is all right so the evenly spaced
cards
okay so inside of the card we're gonna
say okay display
flex all right and we're gonna do flex
direction of column right so that means
that
uh counter-intuitive right i know
because they're going to line up in rows
right we're saying flex direction this
column but they're lining up in rows
right
one this is one row this is another row
and this is another row all right
but for those column or the flex
directional for those
rows we want the justified content to be
space between
and that's the magic right there right
because if you change
uh the justified content let's change it
to something else right
so if you do and i'll do this here so
that you can actually uh visually see it
let me do an inspect
and see yeah so let's inspect it
and we'll do it we don't want to do that
all right let's inspect it and see what
happens when we change it down here
all right so let's see space uh between
space
let's do space evenly to start okay so
space evenly now because this has less
content
it's showing up right so it's basically
saying okay well this is the higher one
this is the lower one
the box stays the same but it doesn't
have that same even flow
right you would think with space evenly
that it would be but it's actually space
between so let's try
center right so now it's scrunching
everything down
right let's do flex end right so then
everything just goes to the bottom right
flex start everything pushes as far as
it can to the top
all right but space between actually
gives us what we're looking for a very
evenly spaced and nice looking car
they're consistent across the board and
that's something that you know
pretty sure that we as developers have
you know fought with before
okay so that's your basic idea behind
that
all right and then this is this is just
allowing um
uh the pancake to stretch right so we're
basically taking that pancake idea
right uh that's another that's another
little trip trick for you right
you can uh make this stretch across
and then it just does the uh the pancake
right so
let's close this out uh let's just throw
in an extra tip the six plus one
all right so here we go right so these
are actually going to
uh yeah they're going to uh just
span across let me refresh that because
they're actually now they're even now
all right so they're going to pancake on
top of one and they're going to stack
and this is without media queries or
anything like that right
so you know that's pretty cool as well
right so you say flex
i think this uh shrink grow and basis
yeah shrink grow basis i think if that's
i think that's the proper order but you
know what's pretty cool
let me show you something let me show
you something i'm just like i'm getting
my
fire marshall bill on right let me tell
you something okay
so i'll show you that right i know some
of you that's like what are you talking
about
uh you strange old man all right yes
grow
shrink basis so if you highlight over it
in css
uh you'll get the mdn reference but you
can also see here
it tells you oh yeah okay it's lex grow
flex shrink
flex basis right i had the order wrong
okay so that's one thing that i found is
very helpful right when i'm like hey i'm
confused about what is this what is this
what does that mean right just highlight
over it and you get that and you can
also click here
and get the mdn reference right you do
option click
and get the mdn reference to it right so
i think that's pretty cool it's
something like whenever you're confused
about anything
css related you can just highlight over
it and it's like what does this do again
right you got the definition right there
and you also can uh
you know command option click and go
outside
um yeah i think i think i have option
click as the one set you may have
something different all right
so our last one the c-span grid c-span
okay
let's close this out because it's
getting a little congested around here
all right
so let's open the pancake layout file
we're gonna command p
i'll paste up sorry command p all right
there you go
okay all right so let's update our
container
to look like this all right the whole
container
it's going to do the whole thing all
right so c-span grid
all right we're going to pull this code
into the pancake
layout uh dot css
all right and we're going to paste that
in and again i will explain as we're
going across
all right as we're going through this
okay so let's go let me get rid of that
pancake layout yes all right refresh
okay cool
all right so this is what we got like
basically it's like the podium at the
olympics right or the
world championships or whatever right
first second and third right
gold silver bronze okay bronze is on the
same level as
as you know silver but you know don't
get too upset
right okay so let's explain what's going
on here all right
so basically it's sort of the same idea
that we were talking about earlier but
there's a couple of different ways that
you can go about
accomplishing it all right so i
basically wanted
these things to show up this is a grid
and i want them to show up
in this order right i want it first to
be in the middle
second and third to be on the left hand
side left and right hand side
up first on the row below all right so
let's go through
how we made that happen all right so
we're saying c-span grid okay
uh and then we're going to say display
grid and then we're going to set our
template columns up we're going to use
the repeat function so repeat is going
to say give me 12
columns all right all of one fraction of
units so even
12 even columns okay that's why these
are all even
right they're all even same space okay
uh and then for the
let's go back here i want to open it yes
all right so we'll see that
that's what this looks like all right
okay
so c sprint span grid is going all the
way across
all right and then uh the span grid text
that's just basically me using what we
what we talked about before this the one
line here the one line center
right so i'm putting my metal in the
center right each way
okay and then the results so this is
where we get some interesting things
going on right the results if you
actually actually had results set up in
here as well uh and it was
expanding the entire column so remember
13 minus 1 would be 12
full columns that's what we wanted and
the background color would have been
wheat but i didn't i decided to remove
that all right but the span for gold
okay so i want to start at column six
and go across
start at line six sorry and go and end
my um in the column uh at line eight or
in my you know
uh what i'm taking up at line eight so
how many would that take away
how many would that take up eight minus
six two all right same thing for silver
i wanted to say all right well i wanna
start at line four end at line six
that takes two now here's a different
way to do this all right
you could say eight i want to take up
eight and i want to span
two it would be basically the same thing
as doing eight ten but you could change
all of these so let's go here and show
you uh let's see pancake
layout all right so nothing nothing
would change if i did
uh if i did span two for all of these
all right so if i go back and i look at
it again right nothing changes but if i
say span
three right yeah so if i say span four
and say well you know what i don't want
i want to spam four but i want to start
two back all right yeah so now i'm gonna
say okay
let me span six right i wanna start back
so now
first is taking up everything like it's
over uh second
and third right i dominate you right so
all right
so i think that's the last uh tip that
we have right and you'll be able to find
a link to the description the video uh
in the video
uh to the github code uh and again don't
forget to like comment and sub uh
subscribe and then share these videos
out
right because we want to keep uh
bringing you uh content on the coding
tech youtube channel
uh for free all right so bringing in
some new content
uh yeah so and then comment below again
and let us know
what you would like to see next thank
you all for all the comments that you
left
on the last video uh the d3 video uh
we're gonna be bringing you some more
uh content like that in the future and
again until y'all till i see you all on
the next one now you see me i don't
really see you but
you know i'll see you all on the next uh
video and happy
coding